[Applause]
it's been 30 years since billboard rain
hold on
song of the year was there a time in
your life that you was kind of exactly
on point you needed to hear that message
oh yeah yeah yeah no I was really in a
dark dark space when that lyric was
written I was really at a point in my
life where I felt like if I was I was at
a crossroads and I really felt like if I
didn't get my life together and stop
like doing drugs and you know had like a
really bad boyfriend at the time and I
just was in a lot of pain and I just
said if I don't if I don't change my
course I'm gonna be in a lot of trouble
so I knew that I was at a crossroads and
that I either had to like hold on for
one more day or just die I need it now
in this world in this time yeah who need
you know inspiration like this and songs
that can help get you through it you
know I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this